what is that this is the Jarrah we had
earlier take it that burner what's that
this is chicken so you got cooked gyro
cooling down and you've got cooked meat
it sat next to raw chicken in a
differentiation in a different tray and
on top of cover but his liver chicken
you cannot store cooked meats anywhere
near raw meats rule number one just
smell that just smell that and smell
that [ __ ] smell fresh melon yeah go
what's it smell off can you tell me what
smells off cuz he's in denial that
sounds like [ __ ] that is disgusting have
you any idea how long a jar needs to sit
what did you find it
why the [ __ ] do you think I found this
if it's old we should have just thrown
out there's no reason to keep any idea
how many years that needs to be in all
these [ __ ] two years all these jars
and my children's life was stored at the
back of the fridge just this has been
eight years of it
that is disgusting what is that how old
are they
that's two days old
it's a funny two days see that their
blood blood from we're going to meet
blood from the meats on the mozzarella
sticks
sorry what the [ __ ] is that these are my
I don't serve basis of mine how many
times a day do you go into that walking
front 100 hundred disgusting
hold on that's broccoli rabe leftover
from my brother's wedding the leftover
from your brother's wedding
have you any idea how bad a Turner needs
to go before gets that bad touch that
just touch just just I'm not serving
we're not using it any idea how bad a
slight avail who needs to go that color
just smell that color I feel bad how
long is that they're turned of in two
days mom oh [ __ ] of two days
what in the [ __ ] is going on the
project's over who rotates the freshness
that's myself really seriously why put
on my limits like that for why are you
taking my product a mold you need pay up
Jesse some all stay that chicken [ __ ]
how we look at this what's this fool
where's that from then shower doesn't
print today those who does you're not
gonna be staring to the public oh we
started a public
I don't you that I'm not gonna serve
this you're saving for what told me that
they're just friends it from this
morning you [ __ ] little [ __ ] up
you're the little [ __ ] tell me if this
were made today
oh you don't [ __ ] believe me
[Music]
Wow chicken breasts oh my god just
dumped in there
no take out the bag that's how lazy they
become and the whole fridge is not even
chilled it's warm there's not a decent
temperature on the floor here that pork
belly kind of carry it back on the floor
next to the pork belly you got cooked
chicken it's actually Heinz sighs just
festered in there that's sat next to the
pork belly you've got cooked chicken
cooked chicken raw pork Jesus Christ
[ __ ] is that some form of chili
my god oh [ __ ] this is bra cool
it's not my fault that you served to me
is it that's our on there old pork of
their lifted oh no that's the old clock
when's this one from not Thanksgiving
again stuff was my strong smell that
smell it that's [ __ ] older than me
smelling yours
that's your saw Sarah what in the [ __ ]
is this oh my god is that flounder
that's my office
definitely old it's green
smell that see the kitchen like this
before
most place is littered with crap what's
that there co2 for the beer
look at those shelves breath grime
that's like 14 years of grime there
Jesus Christ Chef Ramsay was that
oh there's dust here there's this is
just like it's not that bad
what's in here Dara vegetables that's
the vegetables what's this other bottom
ah I supposed to be eggplant eggplant
parmigiana
when were they cooked last Thursday last
Thursday Yard Almighty look at that
Oh fill that something else at live a
feeling I know we just made it today so
what you doing the [ __ ] fridge I know
it's hot hold it
what does hot things do that are sealed
that goes inside the cold fridge the
source goes sour I didn't know that you
didn't know that no suggest you spent
five minutes sort now you ship first
before you start cooking yeah okay
Jesus Christ I should have known better
he's right but he's just a pain in the
ass about it
[Music]
yeah
trash with the rotten vegetables thrown
away order wings please and the orders
pouring in Jim and Geoff get back to
cooking
order green beans please and begin to
send food out of the kitchen make sure
they say a prayer before they start
eating that hey the chicken but the
diner's are less than impressed
they sent us back they didn't like it
they said that you can't eat it what was
this and a pile of mush
does anyone takes anything seasoning
tasting every time a dish came back it
was like losing a customer and it hurts
what was wrong with it it's too flowery
and it makes me feel like a loser I do
really feel like a loser right now Jeff
okay frustrated
I'm working on it
yes I get some fresh air what's the
matter failure you can't give it by that
it's not going right I need to see what
I've got to work with before I can start
looking at any form of change you have
to bounce back okay let's go
Chef Ramsay's right you got to pull
yourself together and get back in there
and get through the night how we doing
doing well sir
thanks to Chef Ramsay's encouragement
Geoff jumps back into dinner service and
tries to help his brother Jim get the
kitchen back on track keep it up Jim
you're doing a good job but
unfortunately he only makes matters
worse
Jim I really now frosted them in the
back I think they were defrosted in the
bag and I ain't Jeff yeah the chicken
tenders what do you do to them to
defrost them I understand table you
defrosted them in the sting table full
frozen
of course now what you're supposed to do
no frozen food needs to be defrosted
naturally right give me the bag where's
the bag Oh God Almighty we can't serve
them you'll [ __ ] kill somebody Jim
talk to me what am I supposed to say
it's a mistake it's a lethal mistake
Oh God
what is that twice baked potato
thank [ __ ] I missed that one twice
so dirty god when was that
cleaned Oh God boys this is 10,000 times
worse than I thought it would be
it's like lava [ __ ] and crap
kitchen help hazard my god stinks as
well
my god that's disgusting
that is off as well
and look some dirty progress picked all
the bones out and just let them on the
side all away come on rich
it stinks so the hoarding isn't just
wash machines and microwaves is an old
first day of this dirty dirty [ __ ] this
this is the desert start preparation
stop light it's disgusting
and these lamb chops and what is satin
what is that yeah yeah you already right
and this here what's that plush from the
Mud Pie bath sat on top of a leg of lamb
that's dripping with blood you with me
the place is littered with [ __ ]
everywhere you turn and for me it was
bad enough to see the crap in a dining
room I didn't expect that walking to be
festering the way it is what in the [ __ ]
are we doing how old is that I don't
know look at the color of the chicken
green and stinking about what this pie
in what we're serving that
excuse me look at the way we were what
is this what is this anybody and now I
hear you've got no idea and this how
old's this oh my god you disgusting pigs
look at that yeah
it's fermented just just just smell that
smell that come on please you own it
ladies you'd be serving that see them
all around the site oh my god oh my god
I thought that was basil oh my I wish
she was [ __ ] basil how long does a
sauce
sit in the fridge to get moldy around
the top I'm quite a long time [ __ ] off
will you touch a wall you dirty Pig this
is disgusting
[Music]